a lot of us wish we could travel the
multiverse pay a visit to another world
and see all the ways in which it differs
from this dimension that we call home
maybe there's a decision that you made
that altered the course of your entire
life what college you went to asking
somebody out accepting a job over
pursuing a passion the question of what
if might have kept you wondering what
your life could have looked like if you
picked the other path surely it would
save you all that wondering and be so
much easier just to go and find out
imagine if you could simply pick a
universe where you chose differently
then take a quick jaunt over there to
see how things turned out for your other
self but what if you couldn't choose
never mind whatever that decision was
what if you couldn't pick where in the
infinite multiverse you ended up if
traveling from world to world was as
random unpredictable and instinctive as
a sneeze what then one moment you're
safe at home surrounded by everything
you know it might not be perfect but at
least it's familiar the next thing you
know with the blink of your eyes you're
standing in a world that maybe looks
similar but giant bees are the dominant
species instead of humans or the world
is overrun by spiders or everyone is
made out of paint needless to say you'd
be at least a little disoriented at
worst absolutely terrified for your life
that pretty much sums up the experience
of scp-507
also known as the reluctant dimension
hopper from the outside he looks to be a
mostly normal human man with blonde hair
green eyes nothing all that remarkable
about him of note save for him having a
somewhat unplaceable accent despite
having a legal name as cp507 will try to
squeeze what little enjoyment he can out
of introducing himself by a different
nickname to everyone he needs previous
favorites have included tommy steve
bruto guy houdini and grabnock the
destroyer we'll stick with tommy the
sole most intriguing thing about tommy
is that through a process that happens
completely without his control he can
spontaneously disappear only to reappear
after an unspecified amount of time
later during that time
scp-507 will have been in a completely
different universe to our own this can
happen at any time of day or night and
usually at the most inconvenient moments
including while tommy is in the middle
of a conversation trying to sleep or
using the um
facilities he has no control over when
it happens however he'll always arrive
in an alternate universe in the same
geographical spot he was in while in
ours if he moves around in a parallel
world then when he returns he will have
relocated to the corresponding place
back in this universe and that's when
disaster struck alarms were blaring
declaring to all staff on site that
there had been a containment breach in
one of the anomalies holding cells all
hands were on deck and security teams
were converging dashing through the
corridors this was the second alert
today at first scp-507 had vanished on
one of his unplanned little excursions
but now it seemed that another scp was
trying to do the same days trying to
reorient himself
tommy rested against a nearby wall his
head was spinning and he knew it would
for a few more seconds he was in a cell
similar to the one he'd just been in
while in another universe except here
back home there was a key difference the
cell was occupied as soon as his vision
cleared tommy looked up at the only
other creature in the room with him it
was a tall wiry humanoid shape
completely hairless with pale skin white
eyes and a large gaping jaw
turning to face him tommy instantly
recognized the creature from a
description he'd been read by a
foundation researcher it was scp-096
uh-oh spaghettios realizing its face was
being observed the shy guy started
screeching first an uncontrollable whale
of distress that quickly gave way to a
guttural animalistic roar of anger it
covered its face babbling to itself as
tommy backed away banging his head
against the sealed wall of 096's cell
then the creature turned towards him and
lunged racing across the room to where
scp-507 was trapped all he could do was
close his eyes tight and think about
running away tommy could feel a headache
brewing in his skull and caught traces
of a familiar flash through his closed
eyelids he gently opened them back up it
had happened again maybe for the first
time ever at a moment when he actually
needed to get away staggering to his
feet tommy looked around he was in the
cell still rather another version of it
in a different universe yet again
knowing that he wouldn't be able to
predict when he would next displace he
didn't want to reappear right back where
he had started with scp-096 poised to
kill him so relocating was top priority
fortunately the cell actually had a door
in this universe and that door wasn't
locked in fact none of the doors were
locked or even guarded and the
foundation facility while looking more
or less the same was completely
abandoned it almost looked like it had
never even been used stepping out of the
entrance tommy trekked his way towards
the city he knew it was a short hike
away and by the time he could feel
blisters forming on his feet he was
close enough that it didn't matter with
another few short steps he was standing
among the tall buildings and
surprisingly empty streets one of the
first things that struck tommy about
this universe was that there were hardly
any people around outside on top of that
the roads were devoid of cars everything
around was so quiet the air was still
and clean when he breathed it in the
sound of footsteps against the pavement
immediately caught tommy's attention the
first sign of anyone else around other
than him racing towards the noise of
another person tommy turned a corner and
bumped straight into an old man in a
long coat who had clearly been in a
hurry and quickly revealed he didn't
have the best temperament either watch
where you're going he shouted caught off
guard by the sight of another person put
on the streets what the hell are you
playing at sneaking up on me like that
you're trying to get yourself killed out
here oh definitely not tommy said
climbing back to his feet hands held out
apologetically i'm so sorry mister i was
just you got a death wish or something
kid the old man demanded marching past
him
no
scp-507 protested chasing after the man
wait what makes you say that as if you
don't know you scoff look around you
look up at the sky there's a storm about
to hit any second now it's a coming and
if you don't get inside you're a goner
what could be so dangerous about a
thunderstorm tommy asked the old man
stared back at him with a look of
confusion on his wise face looking at
tommy like he had just said something
utterly bizarre what the hell's a
thunderstorm the man asked feeling
equally confused tommy craned his neck
up towards the sky looming above were
swirling masses of clouds the kind
anyone would expect to be accompanied by
severe winds and the deafening boom of
thunder but the wind was still and there
was nothing but silence until a choking
gurgling sound came from somewhere
behind tommy's back he spun around to
see the tall wiry frame of scp-096
its long fingers gripping tightly around
the old man's throat it had followed
tommy and he knew that anyone who saw
its face even in a picture would find
themselves chased down on foot by the
creature but he had no idea the shy guy
could travel between dimensions he'd
foolishly allowed himself to think he
was safe out of the monster's reach but
now it seemed to be showing him that the
opposite was true it hoisted the
helpless old man upwards by his neck his
shoes barely able to graze the pavement
as his legs flailed eyes rolling back as
the shy guy clamped his throat shut the
very second tommy turned to run the
clouds turned above and without so much
as a warning the storm hit something
wasn't right tommy could feel his feet
lifting off the ground immediately
panicking as he thought scp-096 had
grabbed him but looking over his
shoulder showed the creature was still a
few feet behind and starting to gently
float up off the ground too
instinctively tommy's legs started
thrashing around trying to gain a solid
footing instead all his urgent motions
did was cause him to start spinning
uncontrollably as the gravity storm
lifted him higher and higher up into the
air spinning him around as he was taken
further upwards tommy caught sight of
scp-096
the shy guy was staying still as if it
was still in control of its body's
motion while he was wildly flipping over
himself the tall pale creature drifted
closer to the side of a nearby building
with tommy being barely able to reach
the top of the street lights as he was
pulled further away from the safety of
having both his feet on the ground just
as he saw scp-096 push itself off the
edge of the building drifting straight
through the air towards him tommy shut
his eyes again and prayed he'd displace
sure enough a flash of light came
bursting out in time with another
headache suddenly he had appeared in the
exact same spot in another universe
however here there was no gravity storm
in progress here in fact no such
phenomenon existed the laws of physics
were much more in keeping with those in
tommy's home our universe of course that
would be more reassuring if he wasn't
already several feet up in the air the
second he arrived tommy started
plummeting back down to earth screaming
as he felt himself falling keeping his
eyes screwed shut as he dared not look
at the ground he was currently hurtling
towards his plummet was broken by
something not particularly soft whatever
it was seemed to tower high enough that
tommy only picked up a few bruises as he
hit it but the fall didn't stop
instantly instead he kept on toppling
through whatever he had landed on it was
some kind of mass piled up almost as
tall as a building a collection of lots
of things that were all brushing past
tommy the more he fell he hadn't yet
stopped for long enough to recognize the
sensations that is until he landed with
a painful thud slowly opening his eyes
back up tommy could barely see anything
in front of him he was so deep in the
mass that the pile was blocking out the
sunlight with only a few beams bleeding
through the gaps but barely enough to
give him a clear view of where he was
tommy tried to crawl forward squeezed
between the heavy things around him
pushing through whatever tiny little
crevice he could find as he did the
weight of the pile shifted around him
and he was worried that any moment he
would move the wrong part of it bringing
the whole structure collapsing down on
top of him like a toppled jenga tower
only big enough to crush him to death he
forced himself not to think about
exactly what the pile was made of either
it was already long past the point where
tommy recognized what each thing felt
like plus there was the added stench
something or lots of somethings rotting
and producing a stomach turning odor as
it decayed even when you're not trying
to look it can be hard to mistake the
feeling of a hand and arm cold skin
against his the light from beyond the
pyramid was getting closer as he could
see was starting to eliminate more of
his surroundings the closer he crawled
to the perimeter sure he could have very
easily used the torch the foundation let
him keep with him but tommy wasn't quite
ready to see what he was crawling
through yet intentionally shutting his
eyes and opting instead to follow the
faint glow and distant warmth of the sun
breaching the outer side of the pile
tommy gulped down lungfuls of air it
barely tasted or smelled that much
cleaner than the air within the mass but
at least he was free clawing himself out
and along the ground he finally
carefully stood up still keeping both
eyes screwed shut part of him really
didn't want to take a look around at
this new dimension maybe if he waited
long enough he would displace again and
end up somewhere with less
decomposing but then he remembered
scp-096 was still after him and he had
no idea how to escape it he needed to
try and figure out what he was going to
do and the only way to do that was to
look around at where he was lifting his
eyelids the different sized masses of
all shades shapes and sizes lay before
him each one was coated in one unifying
color all of them slick with the crimson
of blood against skin tommy could feel
the urge to throw up quickly shooting up
from the pit of his stomach towards his
throat as he looked at the massive pile
of bodies in front of him it was
enormous there were so many dead people
all laying on top of one another that
the pile reached up as tall as office
buildings and the pile that he had
fallen into and crawled his way out of
wasn't the only one either as far as the
eye could see everyone was dead feeling
a heavy sob at the back of his throat
tommy swallowed it when he heard another
sound above the low buzzing of flies
over the human carcasses someone
something else was crying nearby and the
moment he turned around the familiar
figure caught tommy's eye even without
being the only other living thing around
for miles the shy guy still stood out
clear as day it's distress that finding
itself in this horrible dimension
briefly mirrored tommy's own
until it reestablished its psychic link
with its victim and gave chase once more
scp-096 started dashing towards
scp-507 for a split second he thought
about just letting it catch him what
difference would it make in a place like
this but then the hallucinations of
bright colors and a stinging deep within
his skull hit tommy and just like that
he was gone again it was night time in
the next dimension tommy arrived in the
cold air and dim light of the street
were enough to give that away but at
least he was away from that last world
filled with discarded and unburied piles
of corpses he thought to himself surely
he couldn't possibly be anywhere worse
than that now the first sight that tommy
was met with was a huge white lcd screen
big enough to cover the entire side of
one of the skyscrapers facing him
emblazoned against the bright white glow
was a familiar symbol a circle with
three arrows crossing its outline and
pointing towards its center around that
was a thin frame another circle this one
with three protruding rectangles around
the circumference in line with the arrow
tails thick lettered text appeared on
the screen too beneath the emblem boldly
proclaiming that anyone reading it
should submit comply persevere tommy
blinked in disbelief looking around
there was hardly anyone else around save
for a few people staring at him had they
seen him appear or was it just because
he was dressed so differently to them
each of them had on a grimy pair of
overalls sporting more of that same
symbol on the chest and across the back
every wall of every nearby building was
overfilled with posters featuring
matching imagery each one posing
different questions in the same
unforgiving accusatory text against its
clinical white background one poster
read could you be anomalous submit for
testing today another had the following
notice curfew still in effect 10 am to 8
am the following morning all citizens
must comply and one more touting that
only through persevering will we
continue to thrive each of them was
signed with the same name and logo to
match the organization that tommy had
come to put some amount of trust in even
though they weren't always clear with
him but he knew they weren't the bad
guys or at least the version that
existed in his universe didn't seem to
be that bad they had questionable
methods but they weren't evil weren't
this by order of the scp foundation a
loud militaristic voice barked from
behind tommy get down on your knees with
your hands behind your head you will
surrender any anomalous technology and
declare any memetic effects or cognito
hazardous abilities before we approach
you tommy looked over his shoulder met
with the barrels of several automatic
weapons that were now being trained on
him instantly he threw his hands in the
air terrified that this alternate scp
foundation might be far more
trigger-happy than the version of them
he was used to from the look at the
oppressive text on the huge screen the
propaganda posters and the matching
uniforms ordinary people seemed forced
to wear this foundation seemed to be far
more ruthless they had transformed from
a secretive organization into a
full-blown authoritarian regime maybe
even in control of the entire world
ruling with an iron fist on your knees
the commander of the mobile task force
shouted again the aggression in his
voice as well as the several laser
pointers from his men's guns that were
hovering over his chest prompted tommy
to do as he was told do you have
anything to declare before we approach
the mtf leader parked uh no tommy
stammered before realizing that was
probably an inadvisable answer ah i mean
yes i'm i'm scp-507 but that number
might refer to someone different here
look what i'm saying is this isn't my
dimension okay i have a condition that
sends me to different universes at
random i can't control it it just
happens please for the love of god don't
shoot better radio into command the team
leader told one of his subordinates tell
them to run that number against the
archives then inform lord adjudicator
clef that we may have a containment
breach overhearing what they were saying
instantly reminded tommy that he was
still being chased wait he called to the
elite operatives there's something else
you need to know what's that 507 the
commander's side lacking the patience
for this
there's another anomaly after me tommy
explained hurriedly i don't know how
long it will take to get here just that
when it does it'll kill everyone to get
at me i've heard enough troopers take
him away the commander grunted two of
the mtf team rushed up to tommy and
grappled either of his arms not letting
go despite his protests they started
dragging him towards their armored
vehicle looking like tommy was about to
spend the foreseeable future in the
clutches of one of the worst versions of
the foundation that is until a tall pale
creature stepped out from behind the
transport the mtfs were instantly
frenzied and yells of another anomalous
contact were quickly drowned out by the
noise of gunfire all the while the shy
guy was casually moving between the
amassed troops gripping their heads
twisting them all the way around until a
sickening crunch rang out dropped back
to the ground
scp-507 started to feel another headache
coming on knowing that any second he'd
displace again and end up in another
alternate universe and for the first
time today he was okay with that it was
better for their chase to go on if it
meant that him and the shy guy didn't
have to spend another minute in this
universe now if you want to see another
one of the foundation's most infamous
anomalies going toe to toe with another
unlikely adversary from across the
multiverse then go and check out
deadpool vs scp-682
or ever wanted to know what would happen
if a deadly malicious mask was combined
with one of the most powerful reality
benders ever encountered then watch what
if
scp-343 wore scp-035
to find out